[Music]
supply-demand news submitted by it's a
sunny day in korea mmm
call yes similar to Ober supermarkets
are now looking to introduce surge
pricing on groceries that is [ __ ]
stupid
what's surge pricing like antique hours
with uber in order to entice their
drivers to take up more passengers they
hike up the prices for the passengers
and that's like surge pricing so they'll
hike it up like crazy amounts like I
can't even tell you really how much they
hike it up it's pretty good it's pretty
crazy and it depends like how much
demand there is in the area you are so
during the rush hour then a cost way
more because everyone's trying to get it
right yeah it's like in Austin I heard
that like if you do stop by Southwest in
that during that time it's like very
very popular so a lot of uber Xand live
is like more money to drive that time
yeah during a Sundance when we were
trying to get from the event back to the
house at night we had a we added like
basically do this whole back and forth
thing because it was a hundred and forty
bucks to get home gonna be [ __ ] 120 to
160 so man man so we waited until it got
to about eighty dollars and we went back
but even eighty dollars was ridiculous
we a lot of people do that like post
makes does that even when you're like
vacationing that happens like it has its
peaks I don't think they should do out
of the grocery store yeah how do they do
it at a grocery store so like oh today
apples are very very popular so we're
going to raise up the price to $20 I fo
is this like crazy and demand probably
they're saying that they can raise
prices as much as 90 percent no I don't
like this because like I just like you
want to equalizes things so there's like
those crazy rush hour at supermarkets
not urgent Sundays it's crazy people
especially like Costco so I kind of like
the idea of their during the peak times
it's going to be way more and then so
incentivize people to go during the non
peak times and then all that traffic
gets to be more distributed like more
evenly and so now it's not so hectic and
then you get to choose when you want to
get your groceries and the pricing that
you want yeah so if you want cheap
groceries just go like Thursday and
I adore Thursday mornings but I what if
it's like July 4th celebration and the
whole week it can buy a [ __ ] hot dog
for a decent price because it's like $30
then you get to be creative it's kind of
like what buying what's in season
like I think that's like part of the fun
part I don't like doing that on food
because food shouldn't be a luxury it's
a commodity that everybody should yeah
it's something that's that's the one
thing I just dislike about it rides is a
luxury you know I mean so the food is
you're supposed to have it and even like
the way food is priced right now it's
way overpriced yeah yeah
and they already kind of do that with
produce depending on what's in season
what's not and the prices change I would
like it though there wasn't one time of
the day where that's [ __ ] 70 people
in mind just to get a [ __ ] pack of
cheese did you have to do that David yes
if you can't tell I just needed a
[ __ ] block of parmesan and they
didn't have the [ __ ] ten items or
less [ __ ] line open so I don't wait
line I go into a grocery store and
looking at all the food I go in there
for like three items but I leave with
1040 that's my target experience every
time I like Costco because I like their
protein they're like their beef they
always use that [ __ ] UN it's really
good it's great cut great value - yeah
it's like their rib eye it's always on
point everybody's Alicia's got show you
guys yeah so the way that they're
talking about implementing this is that
they will be having grocery stores which
out there paper price tags for LCD
digital price tags which can be changed
remotely like whenever he can always
happen in the fridge of the prices so
like if it's in the man right the prices
go up but if it's too low does that mean
the prices go down because their dad
will make a fair hey nobody's buying
these complex Cumbre nobody's buying it
so I guess what it's the essence for
this box of cornflakes or like this is
about to inspire managers special yeah
they're saying that people can game the
system like that
assuming it was going to happen because
if it's only price go up I'm not down
with prices going up ever ever I don't
like that I don't like it when people
make money I only like it when I make
money I wouldn't like food to be even
more affordable but yeah that's not what
I was imagining we're like you know
right now I think we're all really
entitled we're at I okay we all want
ribeye or something and we all go there
but back in the day wasn't like that you
go to the butcher shop and it's whatever
meat is available at that time so people
actually have a very varied protein
source like one day we might be cooking
lengua at home or one day it might be
pork or whatever but now it's like we
literally get exactly what we want and
it's actually producing an unhealthy
result versus a little something like
this like let's say everyone wants pork
chops at the same time the knowledge of
skyrocket and now people are forced to
get lamb or a fourth and glam might even
be cheaper than chicken or some point
and I think that's pretty true it is
better for an environment but it's not
good for me I think it's different I sit
in America because we have so much
excess it's not going to make it to
[ __ ] again oh man people don't buy
based on what they need it's like you
said to pay basically based on what they
wasn't want grocery stores have such a
[ __ ] excess in in food and produce
it's unreal Oh cricket today so does
this article is that what this thing is
that digital eat pricing has already
been implemented in Europe and here in
the US
really where so I fear is cooler than
Home Depot during all the places that
don't go
you know at home people I used to when I
had a home they already had these LCD
displays like electronic price tag but
what they're talking about here though
is that they're going to start within
the next five years are going to start
implementing it throughout the UK and
then shortly after that it will be
implemented in Australia but what's the
poor people gonna do you just have to
wait when it's not in demand really game
the system so it's like you pour you'll
never feel you'll never understand the
joys of a ribeye steak because it's
going to be super expensive now that's
[ __ ] maybe it could go down if it's
not into
I don't know when it won't be in demand
because they're just trying to match
prices with demand so that's the
essential bottom line just about liking
dese lately I don't know why or maybe
he's got to go to the Chinese market
where everything is dirt cheap all the
time and there's flies on everything but
what to tell ya you could buy a [ __ ]
chicken like six pounds of chicken
breast like five dollars yeah surge
pricing won't ever work at a Chinese
market because they'll be like I don't
care for Chinese New Year if the prices
goes up by buying it they're comparing
it to like with the gas prices like we
all need gas for a car and yes the type
of glove but we're still going to pay it
cuz we still need it so that's the way
they're looking at this too it's like
well if you really need a gallon of milk
and it's like a surge hour or whatever
like that's all you drive your cars car
that's a luxury that's still a luxury to
take the bus I still live without having
a car this is like [ __ ] surge pricing
water yeah you're like you must be very
thirsty and we're the only gas station
for miles and miles and miles guess what
50 bucks for a bottle of the finest
exploitation I raised Oh raised in
Disneyland yeah $6 waters I don't like
that idea
bidding that's crazy to me how much they
charge for their [ __ ] food man and
it's not even good based on regular food
on the outside it's just is good for
what in that team is the option bringing
your own [ __ ]
you could bring your food aside yeah
something did unless you what put it in
the lockers yeah I never knew that yeah
you can bring your own so you go I can't
see a walk through this oh I don't know
about that yeah I'm saying you can bring
your own food I never knew that yeah I
mean like whatever you want to bring in
you bring in my food though not gun
house what'd you bring
well know what I mean like do they have
microwaves like how do you heat up the
food no they don't
it's not food that's what I'm saying is
I carrot stick or celery no or a
sandwich or javabean what are you
talking about which is [ __ ] are you
going to starve if you eat a [ __ ]
sandwich every Wednesday I might as well
kill myself that's stupid because when
you go to Disneyland you don't want to
bring food in there you want to eat that
different now though like but you can
bring your own food it's like they're
forcing you to buy acid I want their
stuff pretzel can't want their
[ __ ] true yeah that's crazy I
don't crave a single [ __ ] food in
Disneyland he has a healthy stuff peple
your ass but have you have their clams
like I'd never looked at my chicken
another just on your head Aman no longer
ever had the churros yeah it's crispy a
day on that otherwise I may take this
team you gotta ask them for the fresh
ones you know that [ __ ] place ruined
me dude
cuz that it's so [ __ ] good then let's
go there later yeah okay because they
use goat cheese caramel oh yeah I was
like a goat goat goat milk I should have
never done a video better yeah what is
that that caramel made it a goat milk
connection
oh god I you're mucho a number wanna
would put you at number one dude there's
a whole bunch of like these like low-key
Mexican joints that are the [ __ ] [ __ ]
in Highland Park and a desert Michelin
star students yeah but how come they so
hidden though like how come they don't
expand the horizon look generic as [ __ ]
what if they was desert races I [ __ ]
destroy that business I'd be so pissed
look like all the restaurants we just
started pricing everything that's fine I
already eat off hours like I don't eat
lunch at 12:00 all right I don't eat I
would probably get the cheapest pricing
all the time no better first because I'm
eating lunch at like 3 p.m. total
there's a probably one of the best
sandwiches on earth yeah looking good I
say go ahead
yes have one a month there's this place
right next to the place I get my car
washed at actually so [ __ ] Mexican
they don't even speak to me in English
so I don't know what the [ __ ] I was
ordering the ingredients you can't get
what do they speak to you in with
gunshot just
like clearly I always be English but
they just witty would just only speak to
me in Spanish so how about I didn't to
use I know but she was like adamant you
know like what somebody talks to you
they could kind of tell that you don't
speak [ __ ] Spanish but she was
speaking me as if I was supposed to know
Spanish so yeah another time so I was
like let me get the poster millon and I
give me that one right there and then
the order in Spanish I had no idea what
it was that's a problem but I only got
the [ __ ] it yet I only got that because
the person before me got it so I'm just
gonna follow what he says cuz I don't
know what it was a number 500 she don't
eat that numbers in there what's not you
sexy [ __ ] useless [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you want to follow us you
could check out all our [ __ ] link to
the description box below you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]